in this next section you'll explore how
app engine can run your applications
without requiring you to manage the
infrastructure
app engine lets you build highly
scalable applications on a fully managed
serverless platform
app engine is ideal if time to Market is
highly valuable to you and you want to
focus on writing code without ever
having to touch a server cluster or
infrastructure
it's also ideal if you don't want to
worry about a page you're going off or
receiving five-time errors
app engine allows you to have high
availability apps without a complex
architecture
so how does it work
with app engine you can choose from
popular coding languages libraries and
Frameworks to develop apps with tools
you're familiar with and then
automatically provision servers and
Scale app instances based on demand
options include Eclipse IntelliJ Maven
git Jenkins and pycharm
that means you can upload your code and
Google will manage your app's
availability
app engine also provides built-in
services and apis like nosql data stores
memcache load balancing health checks
application logging and a user
authentication API that is common to
most applications
app engine offers software development
kits or sdks to help you develop deploy
and manage your apps on your local
machine
each SDK includes all of the apis and
libraries available to app engine
a simulated secure sandbox environment
that emulates all of the app Engine
Services on your local computer
and deployment tools to upload your
application to the cloud and manage
different versions
the SDK manages your application locally
and the Google Cloud console manages
your application in production
use the cloud console's web-based
interface to create new applications
configure domain names
change which version of your application
is live examine access and error logs
and more
there are two types of app engine
environments standard and flexible
the first is the app engine standard
environment which is based on container
instances running on Google's
infrastructure
containers are pre-configured with a
runtime from a standardized list of
supported languages and versions which
include libraries that support app
engine standard apis
for many applications the standard
environment runtimes and libraries may
be all you need
standard environment features include
persistent storage with queries sorting
and transactions
automatic scaling and load balancing
asynchronous task queues for performing
work outside the scope of a request
scheduled tasks for triggering events at
specified times or regular intervals
and integration with other Google cloud
services and apis
there are a couple of requirements for
using the standard environment
he must use specified versions of java
python PHP
go node.js in Ruby
and your application must conform to
sandbox constraints that are dependent
on runtime
applications run in a secure sandbox
environment
this allows the app engine standard
environment to distribute requests
across multiple servers and scale
servers to meet traffic demands
this means that your application runs
within its own secure reliable
environment that is independent of the
hardware operating system or physical
location of the server
the standard environment workflow
typically follows these three steps
first a web application is developed and
tested locally
second the SDK is used to deploy the
application to app engine
and third app engine scales and services
the application
app engine also offers a flexible
environment
if the standard environment sandbox
model is too restrictive for you
the flexible environment can let you
specify the type of container your web
application will run in
this option lets an application run
inside Docker containers on Google
Cloud's compute engine virtual machines
in this case app engine manages compute
engine machines for you
this means that instances are held
checked healed as necessary and
co-located with other module instances
within the project
critical Backward Compatible updates are
automatically applied to the underlying
operating system
VM instances are automatically located
by geographical region according to the
settings in your project
Google's Management Services ensure that
all of a Project's VM instances are
co-located for Optimal Performance
and VM instances are restarted on a
weekly basis
during restarts Google's Management
Services will apply any necessary
operating system and security updates
the flexible environment supports
microservices authorization
SQL and nosql databases traffic
splitting logging
search versioning security scanning
memcache and content delivery Networks
app engine flexible allows users to also
benefit from Custom configurations and
libraries while still keeping their main
focus on what they do best writing code
in addition the app engine flexible
environment allows you to customize the
runtime and the operating system of your
Virtual Machine by using Docker files
as an app engine standard supported
runtimes include python Java go node.js
PHP and Ruby
however in app engine flexible
developers can also use different
versions of these runtimes or provide
their own custom runtime by supplying a
custom Docker image or using a Docker
file from the open source community
so how do these two environments compare
to each other
let's start with a standard environment
which is fast it starts up instances of
your application in seconds but you have
less access to the infrastructure in
which your application runs
with the standard environment you can't
use SSH to connect to the virtual
machines on which your applications run
and you can't write to a local disk
the standard environment does support
third-party binaries for certain
languages and you can use app engine to
make calls to the network
finally in terms of pricing after a free
tier usage you pay per instance class
with automatic shutdown
the flexible environment takes minutes
to start up instead of seconds but it
lets you use SSH to connect to the
virtual machines on which your
application runs it lets you use local
disk for Scratch space it lets you
install third-party software and it lets
your application make calls to the
network without going through app engine
in terms of pricing with the flexible
environment you pay for resources
allocated per hour with no automatic
shutdown
because app engine uses Docker
containers you may be wondering how app
engine compares to Google kubernetes
engine
app engine's standard environment is for
people who want the service to take
maximum control of their web and mobile
applications deployment and scaling
Google kubernetes engine however gives
the application owner the full
flexibility of kubernetes
app engine's flexible environment is
somewhere between the two